salut à vous peuple et d internet
aujourd'hui nos vidéos avec une deux
personnes à savoir monsieur vérino de la
chaîne vernon et mademoiselle c'est
l'image de la chaîne céline âge nous
allons jouer avec les prédictions les
plus raté de l'histoire six ans
mentalisme on aime bien faire des
prédictions essayer de dire va se passer
ça et après il se passe ça il ya eu des
gens très connus qui ont prédit des
choses de ouf
du style internet ça ne marchera jamais
le but du jeu pour eux c'est de trouver
qui a dit ça ou qu'est ce qu'a dit intel
et celui des deux qui va marquer le plus
de points aura le droit de prendre le
réseau social de son choix chez son
adversaire et d'y poster ce qu'il veut
c'est pourquoi c'est pas mal parce que
moi je peux pas perdre alors on pourrait
se dire que j'ai que j'ai fait des
grands de recherche partout sur internet
et c'est vrai j'ai commencé par faire
des plans de recherche jusqu'à temps que
je trouve ce livre par contre j'étais
sonné tiers que j'ai contacté l'éditeur
pour savoir si j'avais le droit de faire
ce livre
ce n'est pas un placement de produit ne
ce n'est pas un placement de produit
écouter bonjour si vous me connaissez
pas c'est pas grave vous pouvez me
connaître du coup bien joué c'est le
sait la présentation les plus nettes de
l'essor des présentations vaincu
personne je suis absolument d'une
implantation ne venez pas me découvrir
je m'appelle quand à qui je pourrai dire
tania tutelle daniel duval et les cas
nourrir ta nea du teil et ben oui bah
voila c'est l'insee 10 h voilà tout cas
voilà est bien contents de se retrouver
ici le matin je tiens à dire c'est qu'on
tourne le matin oui c'est vrai je sais
pas si je garderai cette séquence les
gens vont y aller normalement il devrait
trouver des gens abonnés ils vont dire
déjà bonnes salles de classe bon je
tiens les scores les amis à qui parler
dicro c'est le mec qui a dit les
citations que veut dire quand il a dit
les groupes à guitares vont disparaître
beatles bravo c'est vrai la presse
complète et est retourné à liverpool
monsieur dane les groupes à guitares on
disparaît sans s'adresser aux beatles en
refusant de signer leur premier contrat
et prend la 26éme ans j'ai tellement
génial car il en a mangé de viande à une
carrosserie c'est la boucherie
qui a dit en parlant des ordinateurs et
des capacités de stockage 640 ko ça
devrait être assez pendant tout le monde
[Rires]
140 ko ça devrait être assez pour tout
le monde après la valeur de ce que fait
640 ko absolument par contre alors est
ce qu'on peut voir l' indice c'est en
1981 c'est un mathématicien un
scientifique c'est un mec qui bosse dans
l'informatique donc pas tout à fait
sorti voilà c'est ça est-ce qu'il est
encore là aujourd'hui
oui il y travaille encore dans
l'informatique oui tout à fait
steve une cagoule par contre est-ce
qu'il est le patron d'un grand truc ils
bossent pour une marque française du
coup main à et c'est pas français non
est ce que ce serait pas genre
1 alors quel genre de comptes microsoft
apple là où l'autre microsoft
ouais microsoft bah oui bah en même
temps il y en a qu'un seul c'est billy
et oui ces visites celui-là il a parlé
d'un produit il faut que vous trouviez
le produit un sugar hommes d'affaires
britanniques en le sugar homme
d'affaires politiques en 2005 en 2005 à
10 à noël prochain tel produit sera mort
fini-parti qu'un peu plus de dix ans les
caps août 2005 on pouvait dire quel
point c'est quand même c'était la
dernière année
c'était le mot capote qu'elle était
terminée sizemore portable non je vous
écoute que c'est du jeu vidéo
non lui c'est un homme d'affaires
britannique pas d'ingénieur
d'ordinateurs mais électronique mise aux
dance pop est ça non un clavier dans est
ce que tu crois vraiment jamais quand
les cinq à dix les claviers les gars à
noël j'en suis plus à réfléchir à une
chaise des trucs des écouteurs non mais
c'est pas mal on commence à être dans
l'univers ipod oui évidemment
ah oui à ibos et ou du coup ça va faire
comme on a tourné pendant huit heures
pour un ipod qui a dit dans son temps on
considérera charles baudelaire en
littérature comme une simple curiosité
c'est un rappeur s'est pas booba mais
c'est pas mal mais c'est pas mal donc ça
c'est la foule s'est arrêté c'est à 20
heures un homme politique l'a dit ça en
1867 un auteur lui même
oui verlaine non shakespeare
nollet m houellebecq je ne sais pas on
imagine que c'est quelqu'un comme anne
de relativement connus oui évidemment
sans quoi tout ça pour nous au saut non
voltaire non diderot non il fallait la
voir enfin des noms en plus de ça il l'a
déclaré à l'occasion de la mort de
baudelaire donc celle qui l'aimé pas
c'est un truc à dire c'est qu'une merde
voilà tous considéraient qu'ils allaient
résister
disons que le nom de famille de charles
baudelaire et au début de l'alphabet la
première lettre de son nom de famille
est bien celui dont je parle des digues
ces sadiques et voltaire entame alors un
moteur est 15e
sachez qu'on a commencé à tourner hier
c'est douglas cooper historien de l'art
britannique a parlé d'un peintre vous
allez devoir trop eti en avril catherine
piau
il a dit j'ai longuement regardé ses
tableaux ceux ci sont des gribouillages
incohérent exécuté par un vieillard
frénétique dans l'antichambre de la mort
alors on a là un peu tous dit ça quand
on a vu picasso pour l'heure à la fois
je suis obligé de te mettre du rythme
dans la vidéo elle en a pas c'est moi
qui a dit internet
on s'en fout ça ne marchera jamais
mussolini non c'est une personne éclairé
en 2001 mais non non c'était en 2001 et
c'est quelqu'un
que vous connaissez au moment où vous
connaissez sa fonction ou au moins où il
est et où il travaille telle est donc la
musique oui c'est dans la musique c'est
pascal [ __ ] au joli la joie en fait
j'ai même pas j'ai cherché quel était le
genre de personne qui pouvait avoir un
en plomb pour te dire des choses est ce
un temps de celle que tu as fait dg
d'universal france télécom sa et
explique la vie te dis que toute façon
c'est sûr et certain et il va droit dans
le mur c'est à tichy la france ne
comptera pas 2 millions de chômeurs je
m'y engage
oui le clapot que vous trouviez l'objet
dans ton parent dont on parle là bas
tapadas n'a aucune valeur commerciale et
imaginables
qui donc accepterait de payer pour
recevoir un message qui n'est envoyée à
personne en particulier les cas tous les
big bih plat les les documents qui je
reste un buteur qui est prêt à payer
pour recevoir donc c'est ça c'est pas la
télé à la radio qui accepteraient de
sela c'est la radio c'est le nil a dit
c'est pas la radio il a raison je compte
pas de points en jeu prôné par hasard et
en même temps il ya une vraie logique
derrière ses airs qu'effectivement on
envoie un message qu'il voyage est en
fait il ya un truc là dedans c'est que
c'est pour personne mais en fait pour
tout le monde qui est dit s'amuser avec
le courant alternatif est une perte de
torts de synthes lavalin volts tu as
fait c'est dans ce genre de choses
parlait en fait de georges westinghouse
qui maillent à inventer courant
alternatif
diaconu jour en continu qui sait ça
commence par un e
edison oui
[Rires]
on sait pas je suis vous devez trouver
le magazine qui a dit ça en 1936 jamais
une cuisine ne sera capable de quitter
l'atmosphère de la terre d'un journal un
journal un jour un journal le monde une
collation non pas français
exactement mais il ya times est dedans
et collégial mois chaque instant
l'ignorent de quelle invention par les
tombes mon attention sur l'exploiter
pendant un certain temps comme une
curiosité scientifique mais à part cela
elle n'a aucune valeur commerciale
quelle qu'elle soit micro-ondes
curiosité scientifique
ah c'est vrai c'est la télé non c'est
pas de l'image c'est l'image de l'image
c'est une fenêtre j'ai fait qu'avoir du
son ou bandes avoir ni deux et la
vidéoconférence non boivineau gossé qui
est apporté à la vision la
visioconférence non non
mais me sont passés c'était d'aller
battre tout seul dans un truc là la
voilà pis les les tonga dimanche cinq
hommes vérino faut jeter a prêté oui
c'est vrai j'étais choqué hier on a joué
avec ma femme et mon fils et mon fils et
il nous a apporté à manger en a mangé et
un moment marion c'est tomber quoi ça va
vraiment barder
j'ai dû passer de l'aval et imaginaire
puis laval est imaginaire déjà les
batteries jusqu'au boutiste et même là
j'ai encore posé la pelle ya de l'image
ne se montre pas le cinéma se sont tous
montrés actifs
est ce que vous voulez qu'on vous
remettre tout enjeu sur la dernière
genre mort subite voilà la ola
j'accepte la mort tu acceptes oui mais
surtout pas comme ça sonne mais oui
c'est leur garde à vue parce que tu as
tu peux pas dire bah ouais ok j'accepte
la mort subite une réponse à la fois oui
d'accord rien de réponse dans dénoncera
premier avis farce est d'accord c'est
comme je te laisse le point 6 à 10
l'année 1968 je la salue avec sérénité
en alors attendez les questions une
réponse suivi d'une question
d'abord la réponse droite le fait que ta
question peut servir à d'autres
adversaires exactement
donc c'est quelqu'un qui voit le truc
arriver
brigitte bardot faut à une question pas
oui est ce que c'est un homme
oui ok j'ai décidé d'avoir un truc un
coach avait une piste mais du genre
féminin
alors c'est un homme tue santé et celle
là fait 13 morts
je sais pas si c'est surtout les rangs
messins le génie bientôt je n'y a ni du
nom des chaussettes une question oui
c'est une vraie info bloodrayne c'est un
homme c'est la même question
[Rires]
politico-social oh oui maurice picco
sportif oui un homme politique en 68 ou
politiques bien sûr je n'ai pas le nom
mais du coup en fait
kiki en 68 était au pouvoir et s'est
fait complètement défoncée parce que
c'est un des trucs et marcheront jamais
insistant je suis en train de tuer en
tout cas effectivement c'est lens était
le boss à l'époque magie du néant et non
sa vocation dit
par quelle lettre ça démarre à le prénom
comme certaines sommes pas trop bas rhin
c'est mon fin mais même avec ça mais
c'est pitoyable c'est pathétique tulle à
toi non mais tellement de poser une
autre question dépasse que je suis
vraiment sympa qu'elle est les premières
lettres de son nom de famille des indes
est vraiment sympa mais du coup claude
d'aider des wikis cette personne si vous
l'avez mettez le en commentaire mais je
pense que si vous l'avez vous mettez en
commentaire je vais avoir eu milliards
de commentaire parce que là je pense que
la terre entière là sauf deux personnes
une station assise sur ma droite et qui
quand ils y seront ils vont faire ok ce
programme ça ouais ni pourquoi décalé 14
oui en fait le truc intéressant c'est
qu'il nous dit qu'il ya deux syllabes et
qui a deux parties et toi voici la toi
tu as dit machin nati rhénane en un oui
a dit à papa pourquoi pas c'est en deux
parties donc il ya un des apostrophes
quelque chose tu prend forcément bas 6 6
en deux parties qui est pas de trait
d'union pas y avoir deux quelque chose
d'eux comme no2 de la motte piquet
charles de la motion cru qu'il a dit
deux ou trois mois je m'installe abonnez
vous à cette meuf gaviria
il avait deux ou trois syllabes et c2
quelque chose j'ai donc ça se prononce
guerre
je cherche un endroit pour parce que je
vous écoute depuis tout à l'heure je dis
de prêt n'ont pas investi près de passe
ssh à deux noms lacrouts connais pas
cette personne
moi je ne connais pas et je n'ai jamais
pris un apéro avec cette personne je
suis je suis confuse mais c'est vrai je
suis désolé chose qu'on peut avoir la
deuxième lettre de notre avis
vraiment bien sûr et qu'on serait
ridicule tous les deux quoique si on
avait un qui s'avère on en savait
beaucoup plus vite chat est ce que c'est
chaque 2 way charles de charles de lave
de trois syllabes charles de tata ou
charles dota 2
aujourd'hui le souffle charles de gaulle
de gaulle e3 c'est là bas je vais
pourrir tonton facebook ou twitter sont
le genre est rien elles ont les photos
compromettantes
alors les fautes bas elles sont dans ton
téléphone aussi sévi c'est très bien
attention on va mettre celle là je moi
quand je regarde la dernière vidéo de
céline h
je suis ému et du coup la photo qui a
une photo compromettante de vérino pour
l'avoir je vous mettrais devient du
twitter de rhino dans l'année on vous
dirait voir ça j'adore cette photo
pourrait-on vraiment sincère c'est que
j'avais décidé de me raser pendant les
vacances
non mais non du peuple ils iront voie et
ils n'auront plus des mamans sa
crédibilité va disparaître dans 3 2 à je
suis ravi d'avoir eu vérino et céline
pour cette vidéo je vous mets les liens
de leurs chaînes dans les descriptions
aller checker ça je vous mets aussi le
twitter de vérino dans la description
larmes en même temps c'était pas facile
charles 2 qui douche arnaud n'oubliez
pas de licques et la vidéo allait
vraiment chic et là elle est passée et
vous abonner la nasa abonnez-vous à rien
barrez vous et rendez vous vendredi pour
la prochaine vidéo avait rendez vous
chez décathlon du coup je change de
métier et moi
vendre des chaussures chez decca je sais
pas ou pas jusqu'où
ciao c'était un beau combat j'ai
apprécié ce moment je pense qu'on peut
dire qu'on est vraiment perdant minul
nul c'est à dire que c'est la pièce
victoire du monde ça ces jeux de fabien
tu sais qu'il a appris le bottin parker
s'est abritée web est aussi un moment
faut arrêter jouet favori car je peux
dire que le dimanche quand je vais voir
mes 4
[Musique]